martin nevatalova joins me now uh
martina great to see you first of all
how are you
thank you
i'm good thank you
i want to just play the clip i just
mentioned this is the the female
president of the national union of
students in this country who did
brilliantly to get this job and it's a
wonderful i would say wonderful accolade
for a woman to get to this position i
then asked her one simple question
what is a woman
what what i got to do with the price of
friends peers
what is a woman what do you mean austin
i said ask the next girl do you know
what woman is a woman is someone who
defines as a woman period done not
anyone next guest anyone okay i'm a
woman is that yeah i said next guest
because that's not my secret if i if i
said my word i know you're trying to
trap me and i'm not falling if i say i'm
a woman do you agree i'm a woman
now martina it was sort of comical on
one level but also i found it really
unsettling that here you've got a woman
who's actually a real high achiever
she's become president of national
linear students she was very bright and
sparky in many ways but her inability to
even want to answer that simple question
to me perfectly encapsulated the madness
of where mr bates got what did you make
of it
uh well adult human female is the is the
correct answer uh and i find it peculiar
that we are only seeing this from one
side with trans women taking up space in
women's spaces but we do not hear the
same of men having to define what a man
is
uh so wonder that why that is of course
i again come from from at this at this
from from a sporting uh viewpoint and
and what what is fairness so i really
come from it at this whole issue from uh
from
from position of fairness for for women
and girls competing in sports because
that what sports uh biology matters
right so again up to you to define
yourself how you want but you need to be
able to answer a question the question
what is a woman yes i completely agree
and when you hear the likes of megan
rapino and tom daley now coming out and
expressing their fury that anyone should
be concerned about trans athletes
competing against women again what is
your reaction to that
uh what are you thinking about seriously
because
uh there are groups now that are there
up for inclusion based on self id only
there
you don't even take any hormones you
don't need to do anything at all just
self id as a woman and bingo you can com
you can compete as a woman anywhere you
want so this is how far it's gone and uh
to megan or tom i say put put yourself
into our shoes megan has been there but
a great woodworking teacher of mine said
to me if you don't know a solution to a
problem exaggerate the solution so
imagine if we had a team of 11 trans
women playing against 11 biological
women who do you think would win now
these would be good athletes right they
were good as as men as competing against
males and now they identify as women and
they even go up the hormone therapy for
a year it doesn't really do much it
certainly doesn't mitigate the advantage
that you get automatically when you go
through male puberty which starts at
about 11 12 years old and you see boys
just shoot up
five six inches in a year
and uh and
that advantage doesn't go away so
again live your life to the fullest but
you really can't have it all and sports
biology matters and it's just not fair
to have to compete against biological
males no matter how long have they been
doing the hormone therapy if they've
gone through that male puberty you
really cannot make it a fair fight at
the end at all i mean i completely agree
and what i think is also completely
gratefully unfair is that somebody like
you who's been such a vocal supporter of
lgbt rights over the years and who
formally had yourself a transgender
coach renee richards
that you've been targeted by the trans
activist and branded transphobic which i
just find
frankly i find it sickening that you've
been exposed to that kind of thing
it's it's disheartening really because i
have been fighting for our community for
decades uh and i welcome renee richards
with open arms she's still a good friend
of mine to this day now i'm not saying
that i'm not transferred because i have
a trans friend but ran averages actually
agrees with everything that i say about
the transgender athletes in sports women
trans women in sports so it would be
hard to call renee transphobic but some
people say oh well she's just too old to
know better really she's lived as a
woman for a trans woman for 40 some
years now almost 50 years and you're
going to explain this to renee richards
good to know renee now says herself she
should not have been allowed to play
when she played as a woman in the 70 in
the 70s when she was in her 40s she
ranked top 30 in the world in her 40s
when she had been playing for a long
time so she knows she should not have
been allowed to play then and is
definitely on saying the same things
that i'm saying so are you gratified
martina that it seems like common sense
is finally coming into this debate with
with swimming and rugby and other
sporting authorities now actually saying
okay enough is enough and you see the
british government now being pretty
vocal about it as well
i think i think the the tight has turned
in that we are kind of seeing trying to
find a solution that's equitable that's
fair that's good for everyone um
and and common sense kind of is coming
back into the fold rather than no you
have to do it this way and you don't get
a say in this so women athletes are
speaking out more women athletes are not
invited for the conversation as to how
we can include trans women certainly
girls under before puberty trans girls
should be able to play against girls but
again when you get once you get past
purity it's a whole different situation
but i think the tide has turned in
in a positive way that we can now have a
conversation and see if we can find a
solution you're down at wimbledon um and
uh there's still this running debate of
course about the russian uh tennis
players some of whom are obviously
they're not there because the british
government stands on on sanctions has
meant that wimbledon's banned them
we've had this conversation before but
what has been the reaction down there at
wimbledon do you think about this
decision
look we've known about this for over a
month right so the players have kind of
accepted it so this is the deal nobody
gets points so nobody gets ahead by
playing other than getting a wimbledon
title or getting to the finals and
making a lot of money uh but i think the
players are working just as hard trying
just as hard to play the field is weaker
on the women's side i think we have over
10 players that have not been able
allowed to play so it's it's depleted
the field both on the men's side
obviously world's number one cannot play
so i think it's a really sad situation
there are no winners here and i hope
that this is the last that we will have
this situation u.s open already
announced they will allow russian
players to play and let's just hope that
this horrible war uh in ukraine this
attack on ukraine ends as soon as
possible so you know there's no winners
here at all it's all a self-made
self-made issue and it's just a tragedy
all the way around so i just hope that
this is the last we'll talk about it and
we can get on with it and hopefully
ukraine can get on with rebuilding their
country yeah i absolutely agree uh emma
radicanu our great hope here uh won
today she looked pretty good um it's
been a fascinating journey for her isn't
it because she had a wobble at wimbledon
she recovered and wins the us open out
of nowhere which is one of the most
stunning sporting victories in the
history of sport never mind tennis she's
struggled again since then
to reclaim that kind of level of
performance she's gone through a lot of
coaches coach after coach after coach
after coach what do you make of what's
happened with emma radekaar and what did
you see on court today do you think
she's got it to potentially win
wimbledon
there's a lot of questions so no i don't
think emma will win wimbledon this time
around but certainly has the potential
to win it one day i don't think she's
fit enough her forehand looks a bit
dodgy she's not hitting through the ball
and she really could have lost the match
today but which one played a little bit
better uh but certainly the potential is
there so i think the first mistake was
letting go of the coach that got her to
that u.s open title and uh maybe they
should have stuck stuck with that guy
because he did a great job
since then i'm not sure there have been
a lot of changes
and i think you can get too many too
much information and then you don't know
which way to go because you're getting
so many different viewpoints so you need
to kind of stick with somebody to see if
it works first if you mesh with them in
the first place so i hope she finds a
solution she's a great talent uh and uh
you know i think she she might get into
the second week but i don't see her
winning unless she finds the form that
she had at the us open in which case
anything can happen yeah i agree i think
the thing about emerald economy we just
don't know which one's going to turn up
but when she's on it my god she's
unbelievable martina brilliant to talk
to you thank you so much enjoy enjoy
your time there we'll speak to you again
before the
tournament's over look forward to it
all right
okay cool thank you